hello and welcome to this video
playing black against training day
in c3 sicilian
drawing this line bishop e3
go knight f6 i guess
tend to forget that
takes
yeah i'm a little bit i try to remember
this line i know that knight b5 i think
is not the main continuation in this
in this position but
i cannot quite
remember why
if it is if it is just un
usual or has a problem i know
that long castles is good if
white is not inserted bishop
e3 here i'm
really not sure at all
it actually looks totally fine for white
i
i wonder if i'm just
not i'm just having a real brain
sleepy and completely have forgotten
that this is a
normal line
a bit weird
yeah knight pawn takes interesting
that i did not expect at all
well the c file is open right against my
king so
there is some some logic for sure
so going for bishop b4 check
or bishop d6
in some cases if they like check on c1
king b8 bishop f4 check
maybe bishop d6 is possible
okay this is a slower move
go go to b8
bishop c4 is certainly possible
it's a bit it's a bit lame here king b8
but
it's really tough to
stay on c8 all the time
very very uh um unconventional to have
a key on b8 in this in this opening
line okay um
wow that's not really nice
this one for queen b4 maybe
yeah that could be an idea he has a3
actually a3 is a good move
maybe knight d5 yeah not a fan of this
at all
okay at least i'm getting this bishop
that is uh it's helpful
so this one
okay um knight g5 could be a thing
this looks okay though let's do this
bishop f4 just king a8
queen is certainly very nice on d5
yeah just just going for development
okay stop knight e5
yeah i'm still playing this in a
somewhat
um ambitious fashion maybe this is not
called form
yes activity on the c file but
i have some advantages as well
this is not a really strong pawn on d4
and if i get this
rerouted then my position is really good
or to d5 covering
covering e6 and b7
okay that's ambitious but maybe good
e5
i don't want to give him the d4 square
for the knight
the this is why i didn't take maybe i
could have done that
but this looks okay i mean the bishop is
now
covering c8 so if he moves his bishop
which is
probably forced i think i can simply
grab
this here right why not
i got c8 covered
yeah that should work
doesn't really
seem to be a problem with this
preparing not really i thought rook c8
but
currently just asking the rook here what
it's doing
knight d2 i can actually play this here
right
why do i have something better i don't
know probably not
rookie 7 the rook is hanging so he has
to take more or less
okay
yeah that looks nice
so an extra pawn is good
and the bishop pair on top is even
better
interesting
i don't have to take but
it could it could actually be not so not
so precise to do that
there was no reason yet to
give up the pair of bishops but it's
often an important factor that you can
give the bishop up at the right moment
so i think here i can
take bishop f6 that's f2
and now i just take take the second pawn
g6
oh it's not totally obvious how i
promote everything here
h65
the king takes i have king d5 that's the
idea
i have really bad i played this really
badly
oh man such a totally winning ending and
i'm
screwing this up
and it's probably not even a win anymore
the only one that that can try uh it's
got kingdy too
oh my i'm such an idiot this is so
terrible
absolutely terrible play
that's it's i still have chances oh that
now i have more than chances
it was uh awful technical play
it was just it was just like i don't
know probably i managed to get
i have like this is like -5 yeah i guess
something like that
or so yeah and then i i probably
blundered that down to a draw that that
will get to something like -5 if you
give that
thing a little bit of calculation time
and it's such an
awful technical play
yeah may it's better really to take on
f3 that's possible
not invite the king all the way in but
yeah yeah g6 is really really bad
hmm so computer wants to play bishop d5
and get this here
that is actually a good idea still
dominating everything
and if the king takes this is a tempo
tempo and then you get here actually
i i basically just need to trade this
and
make sure that i enter all the way here
to b2
and win with the a pawn that's that's
one winning idea
g6 i was really not doing this that was
really not good
h4
h6
um now i had
f4
i am that's actually the same idea that
i had just in a better way
you force the capture and then you enter
so
that would have been a lot better and
here this is probably just a draw
and the engine confirms i awfully played
so let me just
check i mean there's some back and forth
with with
no time but yeah here it's still winning
or again winning
bishop f3 yeah this is i just i just
didn't see that he's in time
and bishop f3 is just winning
yeah that's it's basically that that's a
simple supes one the king
the king goes back i go king e5 and if
he moves the knight i go king d5 yeah so
it's actually pretty simple it
that was just awful and here
he should just hold the draw
this went back
and played this this move i don't know
yeah so this one seems to hold
yeah because this is just not working
because of knight deform
and if i go all the way back he returns
that's the problem
okay at the end it had the result that
it should have
but it was just so awful in terms of
technical play
and i i totally forgot how this opening
works
so this this and now ah
knight to g4 is the move
yeah i never studied that line all that
much i was just like i'm trying this a
little bit
knight g4 okay
so if he takes i just take this
okay i felt like i was in some real
trouble here
pawn takes it's not convincing
at least the initial engine eval
e6
i'm not lost here it seems but i have to
play
the right moves knight d5 it did cost
some time he castled knight b6
and this should be okay right
ah okay computer wants to take now on d5
yeah e takes is not a move that i would
really love playing
but rook takes is probably too slow i
would still
probably have played it
um yeah that's not fun
there's always rook c7 as pointed out
here by the arrow or
this one
that's better better than rook c1
now i get get this in f6 95 doesn't work
and i'm actually better on d8 compared
to d5 because i don't lose time with the
back rank
so rook c1 bishop e7 and now white has
to
start to think about being equal somehow
and that is not the way to do it
d5 it looks interesting here
because here knight d4 maybe
yeah the engine is not convinced but
it's an interesting idea but
e5 is it's just refuting it
and you can actually argue
here that um i got something better than
the trades i was just a little bit
concerned about the time but he was
actually lower on time
but okay the two bishop ending is just a
total win i i'm just a
total clown for not winning many many
mistakes
this is also easy
and
yeah well taking on e4 is not good
technical play i mean this is actually
right
i mean i'm fixing the additional
weakness on a3
the computer wants to take but i don't
think this is bad
it would be a bit strange and here i can
go f4 and then e4 that's even
even stronger
yeah so yeah we looked at the ending
already i'm a little bit
a little bit annoyed that i played it so
awfully
all right thanks for watching